bonsoir jean de gliniasty merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire ce que représentent ces
commémorations du 9 mai pour la russie
qui sont très importantes pour le pays
bonsoir oui en effet c'est très
important pour la russie
en fait c'est la vraie fête nationale le
12 juin qui est théoriquement la fête
nationale qui est le le jour en fait de
la sécession de la russie de l'urss
personne ne sait ce que c'est que ce 12
juin donc la fête nationale personne ne
sait ce que ça représente en revanche le
9 mai 8 mai pour nous pour les russes
c'est la vraie fête nationale c'est une
fête de ce consensus est une fête où
tout le monde se retrouve et c'était
évidemment un très grand une très grande
émotion pour l'ensemble des russes il
faut pas oublier qu'ils ont lu la moitié
des morts de la deuxième guerre mondiale
à peu près 27 millions d'années ils ont
payé un très lourd tribut depuis
beaucoup d'eau a passé la russie qui
était un allié dans cette seconde guerre
mondiale alliée de la france notamment
aujourd'hui le président poutine a
appelé le président emmanuel macron il
demande à davantage d'interaction entre
les deux pays c'est aussi le bon moment
pour rappeler ce genre de coopération
alors je crois que nul il ya vraiment eu
un accord entre la russie et la france
pour essayer de trouver cette nouvelle
architecture de sécurité qui j'allais
dire quelles nouvelles jeu et
stabiliserait la situation en europe
c'est une vieille idée russe est une
idée qui a été reprise sous z et des
termes un peu différent par le le
président macron est donc ici il ya une
convergence de fond sur l'organisation
du continent sur les efforts à faire et
donc effectivement l'a7 du 9 mai est un
bon moment pour rappeler ses
convergences et pour essayer de les
faire avancer les on a vu aussi le chef
du kremlin
envoyer un message à ses concitoyens
aujourd'hui le patriotisme aux russes et
plus exacerbée que le patriotisme
français si tant est qu'il existe on a
tendance à qualifier le patriotisme des
autres de nationalisme
c'est clair qu'en d'un pays se sent un
peu en situation délicate en difficulté
s'exacerbe ce type de deux sentiments il
ne reste pas moins que chacun à sa façon
chacun des deux pays a sa façon cultive
le patriotisme pour la russie c'est un
élément que mondiale qui me paraît une
synthèse de toutes les forces puisque la
l'histoire de la russie a été quand même
très mouvementée depuis un siècle à peu
près et finalement par le patriotisme et
par la fête du 9 mai finalement on
retrouve tout le monde qu'on met tout le
monde d'accord à la fois ceux qui ont
été réprimées du temps du stalinisme
ceux qui ont réprimé eux mêmes les
organes d'étaler les soldats les
fonctionnaires les femmes les enfants
c'est un moment de célébration nationale
et d'unité nationale très très forte un
peu comme le 14 juillet france est aussi
la fête de la fédération du monde s'est
retrouvé après après la prise de la
bastille un mot sur les commémorations
du 8 mai ce matin en présence d'
emmanuel macron commémoration a minima
comme ce sera le cas demain en russie le
8 mai n'a pas l'important d'importance
pour la france qu'il a pour la russie
pour la russie c'est un monde
célébrations nationales très fort c'est
là bref la vraie fête nationale en
france le 8 mai la vraie fête nationale
militaire en dehors du 14 juillet c'est
le sait le 11 novembre c'est la guerre
que nous avons gagné nous pour
l'essentiel le 8 mai s'il n'y avait pas
eu d'action du gnl
de gaulle la france n'aurait pas été à
la table des vainqueurs et la france je
sais donc c'est une victoire contre le
nazisme et c'est une victoire ou la
france n'a pas joué un rôle aussi
déterminant que le 11 novembre et bien
deuxième élément aussi qui jamais ne
s'est faite cette célébration une
célébration un peu moins significative
c'est que depuis la construction
européenne on essaye de pas trop trop
souligner les guerres que nous avons pu
faire avec l'allemagne
alors c'est intéressant puisque
l'allemagne elle fait pour la première
fois enfin commémore en tout cas pour la
première fois cette date du 8 mai c'est
un c'est un symbole je crois que c'est
un symbole très fort je crois que ça
signifie que la question du nazisme et
de plus en plus clair de plus en plus
clairement assumée par les allemands et
que l'allemagne
ça n'est pas ça mais pas le nazisme
comme la france n'était pas le
collaborationnisme de vichy merci
beaucoup jean de gliniasty d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france